the site of Saudi officials showing
journalists the inside of cupboards in
their Istanbul embassy as if to prove
there were literally no skeletons in the
closet is one of these strangest things
I have ever seen on TV news
it would have been comical were it not
so sinister the reality is that Jamal
khashoggi The Washington Post columnist
and critic of the Saudi regime entered
that embassy on the 2nd of October and
was never seen again
claims he was murdered inside continue
to mount Turkey believes he was killed
and dismembered by a hit squad from
Saudi Arabia who arrived specifically
for that purpose the kingdom rejects the
allegations but has offered no evidence
that he's alive what happened none of us
know but what we do know is that we prop
up this kingdom already drenched with
blood on its hands for the impending
famine in Yemen by selling them billions
of pounds of arms goods and services
this Saudi regime is not a trade partner
but a pariah it's time we stood by our
so-called British values and started
treating it as such at the risk of
having you scream so much you lose
what's left of your voice and well done
I know you're battling through so thank
you very much I want you just briefly
briefly while you were if you'll allow
me play something from Donald Trump
speaking on the 13th of October but when
we take away a hundred and ten billion
dollars of purchases from our country
that hurts our workers that hurts our
factories that hurts all of our
companies you know you're talking about
five hundred thousand jobs so we do that
we're really hurting our country a lot
more than were hurting Saudi Arabia and
that in reality I think is the truth
therefore we if we lived in a perfect
world then that would be fine we live in
and yours is a perfect solution in a
perfect world we live in an imperfect
world
I loathe what I think has happened to
that jokes about our Deen almost
certainly what happened to that
journalist and as details emerge they
are sickening and harrowing as to what
it would appear how they tortured him
before they probably killed him
I loathe what's happening in the Yemen
the reality is by Britain stopping that
and it's impossible to get a direct
figure we tried at the radio station I
work at LBC there's around 240,000
people probably work in the armaments
let's say 10% might be at risk how would
putting thousands of British star
British men and women out of work make
the situation better all they would do
I'm sorry to say is they go and buy the
weapons from the US they go and buy the
weapons from China they go and buy the
weapons from Japan
so in summary sadly we live in an
imperfect world yours is a perfect
solution and it doesn't you know I hear
you Nick and just to give you a figure I
know it's difficult precise figures on
jobs and money but this is the amount of
military equipment we've sold to Saudi
Arabia since the start of the war in
Yemen in 2015 the figure that we have is
four point seven billion pounds and I
just want to play you a clip from the
shadow foreign secretary April a bit
Emily form brain and this is what she
says there are certain standards which
we have to uphold and the crown prince
is not upholding them and we should at
long last start saying so the British
people have had enough labor has had
enough I've had enough what's the matter
with the government you know Nick I I
hear what you're saying nobody
dismissively rights off thousands of
jobs in Britain and income in so our
Treasury much-needed income but
everybody accepts that we have lines we
wouldn't supply arms for example to
North Korea there are regimes that we
would not do business with even though
it would bring in more money and create
more jobs we do have values and we do
have standards and while I am not
dismissive of the benefits of doing
business for Saudi Arabia I don't think
that these things are separate the
reason that Saudi Arabia knows that it
can behave like this is because Donald
Trump wants 110 billion dollars worth of
arms deals that we want the billions
that we have invested in Saudi and that
is why it feels able to behave in
complete violation of every
international rule and standard and I
think that we have to take
responsibility for our all in that I can
sense you wanting to come sometimes it's
a case of you need to keep your enemies
closer
you know I'm saying it whereby if we if
we let those those arms deal slip we
wouldn't know what was going over there
there would be so there's a lot there's
a lot of bigger picture behind this than
what you probably think the other thing
is we don't actually know where honey
was ensure that these kids that was
killed in the embassy do it yeah
way out make this with a rogue he's
justifying what he's doing by saying
basically the same as I am if if you
don't if you would you can face these
people that work in these factories in
this country that doesn't have a job
because what's going on over there it's
gonna happen anyway they'll just go to
Russia or somewhere like that
it's insane they will do it so you're
not going to sort out Middle Eastern
politics by by not selling them some
gear but what you are gonna do is keep
your finger on the pulse and know
exactly how much is going and what what
and then some respects where you can
work out what's what's being done with
that kit it you're speaking as if
there's no cost there's only a benefit
there's jobs and there's income there as
if there's no cost to the decisions we
make this is about what kind of country
on what we stand for everybody in this
country stands to lose if we don't have
values that we live by so what I would
say on this is that I think of stopping
selling because I think the Saudi regime
is terrible for various different
reasons not just their involvement in
Yemen is it's shocking and you know we
could go on for quite some time saying
why and all the things that they're do
wrong so I don't support that regime in
any way shape or form but what I would
say is just all is independently saying
we're not going to sell you arms I think
it's gonna make no difference whatsoever
to their regime and what they do because
I was clearly quite bored this week
because I read Saudi Arabia's 2030
economic development plan that's how
bored I know I know and actually if you
look at what they saying in terms of how
they view their economic development
they want to reduce their dependency on
oil exports and what they're saying is
they spend a shoot I think it's the
world's third biggest military spender
and they only spend two percent of that
spend within their kingdom so their
ongoing strategy what they want to do is
they want to actually build arms you
know manufacturing capability within the
kingdom so they don't want to stop yeah
they don't want to stop their bombing
and their killing and all the rest of it
that's not their intention they do want
to localize their spending so I think I
was saying to Saudi we're not going to
supply anymore is irrelevant it won't it
won't stop them the only thing that we
could do that potentially would have
impact is trying coordinate some
centralized attempt to say to Saudi this
is wrong but every
like the u.s. they supplied bombs that
killed schoolchildren on a bus and they
still sell to them so unless everyone
comes together you're Russia's you're
China's your UN mission yeah and just
bring you in drove the US and the UK
together completely dwarfed all other
supplies of arms to Saudi Arabia we are
the second and we our role is
significant it's not that every other
nation is supplying arms in the same way
we are we are the leader after the US
and supplying arms so we divided if we
decided to change our start it would
send a very powerful message to other
people on the international stage Trevor
yeah I think before we talk ourselves
into
let's do nothing I mean let me be clear
I do understand why this is important
your point fill and the government's
given us a statement which says that
takes its export responsibilities very
seriously operates one most robust
Export Control regimes in the world the
defense sector supports 7,500 small
medium-sized enterprises in the UK
supply chain alone with export orders
worth eight point seven billion over the
last five years now I get all of that
and that's why we probably won't do
anything on arms but that doesn't mean
we shouldn't do anything I think that's
completely right here we can't just go
out a bit of a problem for us let's
leave it to somebody else I mean I think
that I don't do in that foreign
secretary spoken yeah yeah the foreign
secretary issued a really explosive
dangerous piece of paper I think we can
do some more serious things I think that
actually one of the things we could do
which I think would hurt the Saudi royal
family far more than losing a couple of
planes is simply refused their tourist
visas we should refuse their student
visas actually these things are more
important to the Saudi royal family who
are the people who actually can make
this decision and do these things or
stop selling arms and do well we've got
we've got we've got arms deals in train
I don't think we can stop them and I
don't think in riah in reality we are
going to I mean let's be realistic we're
not going to stop them but that doesn't
mean we must do nothing I think we can
punish and I'm being specific here the
Saudi royal family because the access to
frankly British
shops and British companies is more
important to them as individuals than
anything that they can your point that
they'll buy the arm from somewhere else
is probably right
but we can punish them and we ought to
be punishing I don't disagree with that
and having been to Saudi a number of
times myself I find it extremely
repressive coming from the outside in so
yeah I do believe they need right they
are one of these people that Dooley rein
in in a bit with the arm turning in
particular you know it's better the
devil you know sometimes the other thing
I do is I I didn't count all those
Ferraris that sir that the Saudi princes
drive round central London every day
tomorrow there'll be a conversation
pretty quickly about I have here is
hypocrisy because there are other
countries which do similar things and we
condemn them immediately and
unequivocally when a journalist is
murdered in Russia within 24 hours we've
issued a statement condemning it it took
out foreign secretary a week them the
killing it well it believes comment it
took a week to comment and now there's
this well it would be nice if we did
something and I think that it's very
difficult for us to hold ourselves out
as a country that has some moral
leadership in the world as we do and at
the same time you're very selective
about when we enforce it against people
who we consider our friends and if we
want Saudi Arabia to be our friend then
we're going to have to change what we
say about what our values are